joe biden this is unheard of in in
modern
presidential politics joe biden has
effectively
sworn that he won't campaign anymore for
the last two weeks
of this race that's very strange he
thinks he's in a good position he thinks
the polls are behind him so he's just
going to stay at home so he doesn't give
himself the opportunity
to screw up any more than he already has
nobody is trying to get him to show up
out of the mainstream media
out of the democratic establishment the
only guy who is trolling biden into
getting back onto the campaign trail
is the master troll in chief president
trump who says that joe biden
has basically given up on life
no no he has he's waved a white flag on
life
he doesn't leave his basement joe
biden's been accusing trump of waving
the white flag of coronavirus
surrendering on coronavirus he said no
i'm not doing that
joe biden's waving a white flag he's
waving a white flag on life because he
knows that if he goes out and he talks
and he says hello to anybody
he's going to screw up so he's hiding in
his basement right after trump says this
what happens joe biden decides to come
out of hiding
i'm i'm not sure that this corruption
stuff it really matters but biden is
hiding anyway because he doesn't want to
have to answer questions on hunter
he doesn't want to have to answer
questions on
on any of these other people so joe
biden shows up
and he's at a campaign event they've got
a band there and he's going to go give a
speech
you've seen the trump rallies you've
seen what 20 000 people there 30 000
people there sometimes
and then you see the biden rally joe
biden shows up the band is playing there
were probably
18 people in the room he walks down the
stairs
they're playing midnight train to
georgia which is kind of a depressing
song
to be playing during a campaign right
because it's all about a guy who failed
that la was too much for the man and so
he's leaving the life he's come to know
biden's got his little circles there i
don't even know if it's 18 people it's
not it's not even 18. it's probably
a dozen people okay a little bit more on
the side so okay
18 people you got probably more staff
there than guests
and he's he's old so it's taking him
forever to walk to the stage
he's trying to run a little bit but
that's awkward
handful of claps
[Music]
he's leaving he is leaving on that
midnight train
i know that the polls say that biden is
way up maybe biden is way up maybe
biden's going to win maybe it's going to
be a blowout for joe biden
but you've got to admit it's kind of
weird that trump gets
tens of thousands of people to show up
to his rallies and joe biden can't get
20 people to show up to his rallies
you've got to admit that is kind of
weird
i've never seen enthusiasm so skewed
in a race where the poles are so tight
what does that mean does that mean the
polls are wrong does that mean that libs
are so afraid that they're just staying
in their homes
because they're afraid of the flu what
is it what does that really mean
so biden can't muster any of these
people to actually show up
i think this matters much more than the
corruption i think we got to focus on
how there's no enthusiasm why there's no
enthusiasm what his plans will mean for
the country for the economy
what his plans will mean socially what
his plans will mean for the structure of
our government court packing
and what his cognitive issues mean
for the presidency joe biden was asked
one of these events he was asked about
amy barrett
and this should be a slam dunk this is
one of the
top issues on the entire campaign the
supreme court and this confirmation that
just happened a couple of days ago
joe biden he couldn't seem to string the
thoughts together
here's the deal one of the things that
that is important
is that um
keep in mind although they're going to
vote on
uh uh barrett
i think
that is so embarrassing
it's embarrassing for joe it's
embarrassing for the campaign
senator tell us about amy barrett okay
well here's the deal
the thing about it is uh they're gonna
vote today or is it yesterday or they're
gonna
uh uh who and i actually i don't even
wanna make fun of him for it
anybody who's had aged friends or
relatives knows this happens
you know it's a senior moment except
with joey has senior moments all of the
time
don't begrudge him that you know it's
going to happen to all of us probably
someday if we live that long
but it doesn't mean that you should be
president while you're having those
issues
if you cannot give an opinion on the
supreme court confirmation that
just happened you should not be
president you don't have the stamina
to do it and his campaign staff knows it
we've been seeing this for months and
months and the mainstream media are
denying
where joe will start trying to talk to
the press and he'll start rambling
and they will take him by the arm and
lead him away
like come here come here old grandpa and
so come here come here old joe
you know let's go we're gonna again if
if joe were just their grandpa perfectly
fine a lovely interaction but he's not
he's trying to be president
oh barrett the today is sort of okay bye
and just leads them away and the press
won't ask a question about it
because the press are campaign
operatives for
for biden now some of the biden gaffes
have been
a little bit funnier maybe they're
freudian slips i don't know
just yesterday joe biden was talking
about
about his wife and then kamala harris
and kamala's wife
but my wife jill as you know and doug
imhoff uh
commonly's wife are there common will be
back uh later this week i think on
friday
that may have been a freudian slip which
is obviously where you say one thing but
mean your mother
so joe talks about commonly wife he
meant to say her husband i guess
those issues i know it's
counterintuitive but i think those
issues are going to matter much more
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
you